there was a new cpac straw poll done
this weekend at cpac
and although donald trump is still
leading the 2024 presidential straw poll
ron desantis is polling higher than ever
before 28
and trump is furious so
we we want to kind of
consider this story
in the right context trump is still
winning the straw poll
but the margin by which he is winning it
for the 2024 republican primary is as
small as it has ever been
the hill reporting trump wins cpac straw
poll as desantis support grows
former president trump emerged as the
clear winner
but
ron desantis is now up to 28
recall as the article does that in last
year's straw poll desantis had 21
support in third place was trump's
former secretary of state mike pompeo
with 2
support
so
trump has been furious
about what's going on with desantis for
a long time now you might remember that
in november i reported to you trump's
ire grows as desantis's popularity with
republicans takes off and at that point
desantis was only polling between 10 and
20 for the 2024 republican primary
depending which
poll you looked at and what's at issue
here and what trump is so enraged by
is that a number of times now when
desantis has been asked do you rule out
running for president in general or do
you rule out running if trump runs and
desantis has not ruled out either and
why would he when you're polling 28
and it's years from the election and you
haven't even really talked about running
you genuinely have a good shot at being
the republican nominee desantis would be
crazy if he has any even possibility of
ambitions to be the republican nominee
in 2024 descendants would be crazy to
rule it out so of course he hasn't
and trump's furious
since then trump has gone at desantis
and desantis has also gone after trump
saying things like for example
desantis i don't know that i should have
aligned myself so closely with trump
early in the pandemic
might have not been the right decision
trump going back at desantis the order
doesn't matter but going at each other
saying uh you know he's ungrateful and
he didn't really even do that great of a
job with the pandemic or whatever the
case may be
and one great way to trigger donald
trump
is to not be 100
subservient in every single way and don
ron desantis i've said before i believe
ron desantis is sort of like a more
dangerous version of donald trump in the
sense that it's the same
wacky
right-wing ism completely disconnected
from reality facts empiricism etc but
desantis is slightly less cartoonish
than trump he's still a cartoon i mean
compared to you know old school
republicans desantis is still a total
cartoon
but he is more competent he's less
obviously clueless and he might be
more able to actually get things done
in the sort of trumpian vein and that
makes him a very dangerous guy so
uh the the prospects for the country are
of course concerning in the sense that
when a governor
with
endless unnecessary coveted deaths is
seeing his popularity take off
that should raise a red flag for all of
us
at the same time we saw 70 million
people vote for the completely
moronic donald trump
who has even more deaths than that on
his hands with his sheer incompetence on
the pandemic and so it's been a serious
problem for a while uh i do think that
one of the best possible scenarios for
the left and for the democratic party
because the left in the democratic party
are really not
indicating to me
that they have any ability to seriously
win an election unless someone really
helps them out i'm hoping for help from
the republican party for democrats in
2022 and 2024 and one of the best things
i can think of that would happen would
be that trump and desantis get into a
really protracted primary battle
and when we're already talking about
56-28 i mean trump's still winning but
56-28 this far out from 2024 signals
that desantis really could be a very
solid challenger to trump and i think
democrats have to hope for absolutely
anything they can to help them out
um what will ultimately happen i think
we won't know until after the 2022
midterms and this is again why i
continued telling you guys
in in some way trump seems determined to
run in 2024 even at the cpac speech over
the weekend trump said in the clearest
terms we've heard so far
we did it twice and we're going to do it
again in november of 2024.
i have not heard trump more clearly and
forcefully say i plan to run than that
at the same time
i do believe that if the trumpian wing
and trump's endorsees
get crushed in november
i think michael cohen is right remember
when i spoke to michael cohen michael
cohen said he doesn't think trump will
run
because trump can't stand losing again
and of course the question is will trump
believe that he can win
or will trump come to realize that he's
destined to lose and on that basis what
will he decide in the immediate the best
thing we can do
is minimize losses in november maximize
wins if there are wins to be had
and foment this um
split
between desantis and trump because we
have very little else to be shooting for
right now i wish it were i wish it were
different but that is the the reality
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show after
this short break i will deliver the
state of the show address and tonight
i'll be live with joe biden's state of
the union address on youtube twitch and
facebook and i hope you'll join me for
that
if you're like me you love documentaries
and you should really check out our
sponsor curiosity stream the only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries curiosity stream has a
better selection of documentaries than
netflix hulu and amazon they always have
the newest and most critically acclaimed
titles including a bunch of stuff i
can't find anywhere else i just finished
watching fiddling it's about bluegrass i
know so little about bluegrass
it's pretty fascinating and i watched a
documentary about it fidlin i've been
using curiositystream for over a year i
always have it going on my tv in the
evenings you really can't run out of the
amazing content constantly adding new
stuff if you want to deep dive into a
thought-provoking new topic they have
documentaries if you just want to unwind
and turn your brain off
they have documentaries there as well
right now curiosity stream is giving my
audience 25
off that comes out to just 14.99
a year a year
that's just a dollar 25 a month go to
curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below